thanks everyone for making out the time
to attend this presentation
as the title says this is about
inequality joins and pandas with pie
janitor
a bit about me my name is Samuel or
Vanilli I'm a data engineer a Nigerian
Australian living in New South Wales
I love open source I'm a contributor to
Pi genital and Pi data table
this is an outline of what we'll be
going through intro joins look at the
algorithms performance and future work
so let's start with some intro why
bother about inequality joints what
Sparkles do they serve
say you're a cloud engineer and you need
to find out about revenue or utilization
trends inequality joins is something
that can help you with us if you look at
the question it says look for a customer
from the west coast and rented a virtual
machine for more hours than of course
not from the East Coast but paid less
now we'll look at some other questions
but I want you to have a look at the
trend as we proceed
so let's go to the next slide I'm a
retailer
I want to make profits so as much as
possible I want to maximize my profits
and reduce my cost of storage inequality
joins help here now I want you to have a
look at the words there you can see more
than less if you remember from the
previous slides there was that same
points there more than less an
inequality non-equity there's an
imbalance to keep that in mind we won't
talk about inequality joints they are
not equal there is an inbound on
somewhere
tax audits you want to find out who ends
more but pays less tax compared to
another employee inequality joint comes
into play again look at that comparison
a greater than a less than a higher and
lower there is an inequality
same for events for time management you
want to find out overlapping events
again there is an inequality in the an
inequality joint can help you with that
but before we go further with inequality
joints what exactly are joins
at its simplest points as a name or the
title says a join is where you combine
two data frames to form one
at its very naive points a joint can be
a Cartesian join in which case you're
joining every role from one data frame
with the other data frame so if you look
at the image we have the data frame one
the data frame two and then we're
combining every one of them with each
other so you have about nine rows all
together that is at its base the
Cartesian join
however
pandas SQL
engines and all of that have found
efficient ways to deal with joints the
most popular join is the quality joint
you're comparing on something so if you
look at the data frame one data frame
two we're saying give me the rows where
the values from the left column match
the values from the right column in this
case we can say that it's two and three
again it's an important to join this is
not an inequality again equality there
is no imbalance this is equal to that
inequality joint however is either
greater than or is less than or it's not
equal to it's never equal another or a
synonym for inequality join is a
non-eque joint
you could say a conditional joint but
more often than not to hear the words
inequality and non-equity so for this
example we're saying give me the rules
where the values from the left column in
df1 is greater than the values in the
right column in df2 and the orange bars
points us to the rules that fulfill that
criteria
a subset of the inequality join is the
rolling join
in which case you're not interested in
getting all the values you want
specifics is either you want the very
first March or the very last match or
the closest match it's
you find applications usually in Time
series so for this case we say give me
the very first match where the values
from the let's call on the df1 is
greater than the values from the right
column in df2
in pandas because the focus here is in
pandas the equality joint is efficiently
implemented
the role in joy is efficiently
implemented from the quality joint it's
a harsh join the rolling join you have
to Source your joint column and then you
there's a form of binary search
the inequality join however is not
implemented in pandas so what you have
at the moment is you have a Cartesian
joint where you lump everything together
every Row from your left data frame
which will write a data frame and then
you prune it down to just the values you
want now for small data size relatively
small data sizes it doesn't matter it's
okay to go with that but as your data
size increases
it becomes inefficient it becomes
non-performance
and we need an efficient implementation
for inequality joints and pandas I have
to mention at this point that there is
the interval index in pandas that can
help with inequality joints however
it's only efficients when you don't have
overlaps in your data if there are
overlaps in those intervals you lose
that efficiency you essentially have to
do a for Loop to be able to pair your
data accurately the last one there is
just how it looks in SQL SQL is a
wonderful
language once you get used to it so yes
as I said when you did an efficient
implementation for inequality joints and
pandas because of what it could help us
to solve and I just went ahead and
implemented it in part genital
and the name of the function in power
genital is conditional join
basically this is the API for rigs
and the focus for this particular slide
is on the variable ads which is where
we're passing the columns that we need
to process
uh it's cold it's it's so cool so column
from your left data frame column from
your right data frame or a name series
and then your comparator your comparator
can be greater than less than multiple
two and depending on the scenarios you
can even be an equal tools or comparator
so what do you do you do your pip
install per genital
and then you import janitor again
observe people install pie janitor and
then import the genital progenitor is
basically a part of a library from R
janitor the initial aim was to provide a
clean an API for cleaning data easily
but over time the goal spread and went
further than its original intention
let's look at some examples on the usage
of
the conditional join
on data frames and pandas so we have df1
and df2 we have uh the values right
there
if we run it with the Cartesian joint or
the cross join you first build up your
data frame and then you shrink it that's
what you have in cell five
in cell six we just have is your left
data frame your right data frame and
then your support the support has the
column from the left data frame the
column from the right data frame and
then what are we comparing on so
basically let's greater than whites
let's look at question one where we're
talking about Revenue our utilization
trends for say a cloud engineer
this involves more than one condition
it's less than West and the second
condition is greater than West based on
revenue and costs
create our data frames
and then when we
compare them the first one in cell
number 13 a Cartesian joint you do that
first and then you felt you filter your
data to select your specific columns
look at the formats in the conditional
joint again your left data frame your
right data frame and then you pass in
your variable arguments duration time
less than rev costs greater than and
then you can pre-filter your columns
columns from the left data frame column
from the right data frame
let's have a peek into the algorithms
before we look at the performance and
why this white conditional join is a
better option when you're working with
inequalities compared to a Cartesian
join
and it's called the
algorithm is based on sorting and binary
research there are some other
optimizations that I did on myths but at
its core that is already starting plus
binary section
so let's take a single inequality join
taking the df1 and df2 that we're
looking at all earlier on this amount
was saying give me the rules we're left
straight to the right so we find the
positions we do a slice and then we get
our matches
we have a look at the same inequality
join this time around we're saying the
left is less than the right we get our
positions we get our ends and then we'll
move and then we'll capture our points
again have a concept of how this works
let me take you back to the previous
slide we can see again see take for
instance the volume number three it
starts from that end you get all the
values zero two whereas when we're
getting from left to right we're moving
in the other direction
it will play a bit of a pause in the
idea what we'll deal into multiple
joints
specifically rain joins rain joints are
the more popular multiple joins multiple
inequality joints
that can be found so basically you're
saying maybe a between B and C or a less
than B and C less and C greater than D
they are between the range they are
opposing operators
there are two implementations of the
Ring joints in per genital there's one
that was implemented with number one
without a number so the first
implementation I did was without number
and then I realized that we could get I
could get more efficiency by
implementing it in number one reason why
we went for a number is because per
genital stripes on Simplicity we want to
make it easy for contributors to
join and make contributions to the code
without a without that high barrier in
terms of maybe using some other language
that might be hard for them number
offers that simplicity so we decided to
go and do a number but let's look at
this first one where we're not using
number
it's based on an article by vertical
vertica is an SQL database
company and the whole idea is get your
positions for the greater than join it's
related to get your first position and
then complete Ultra matches one concept
I want you to have at the back of your
mind is
it's all about dealing with it's all
about reducing your such space
performance is all about doing as little
as possible the less number of roles you
have to deal with the more performance
your operation will be and that is the
whole idea whether we're using the
number version or the non-number version
the whole idea is I want to do less so I
can do more
so let's take an example we have df1 and
df2 I want to find the rows where the
value underscore one is literally the
value 2A and value 2 b
the first thing we do is we get the
position so the greater than join in
which case we sort
the first one is result on value
underscore 2A
for this particular Ranger without
number the rights data frame is a driver
so with socks on the First Column is
such an ascending order
we get our positions use a binary search
you get your position so let's take
excuse me take for example the value
number four we can see that its position
is
six so everything above position 6 4 is
greater than that now if we stop here
what we have to do now is go take the
value number four and check each
position within value 2B all the way
that's from zero to five and find the
rows where four is less than one two B
for small data that might not be a
problem but want to be more efficient
again the whole idea is do less work as
much as possible and that is where the
next step comes into play
gets the minimum position
that value underscore one is less than
volume and step two B
so when we look at the value number four
instead of us going all the way to zero
to do our search space we find out that
the very first points where four is less
than value underscore 2B is right here
so we as such space is reduced to just
two points so instead of about searching
from zero to five we're just searching
four and five if you take the value
number seven
we can see that its lower boundary is
six when we come to value on the 2B we
realize that the very first point where
seven is less in value underscore 2B is
value 9 which is position six six there
is nothing to search to get rid of that
again we are pulling as early as
possible and we are dealing with a small
as possible such space as we can get
to do our computation we do our search
and then we'll get our final results
there are some observations with this
particular implementation the iteration
is done the iteration is a for loop it's
done within Python and for Fairly large
data it may impact performance that's
one thing to be aware of the other part
is when we get our search space we blow
it up so that we can compare and then
basically we're using numpy broadcasting
depending on the memory side depending
on the data size that can impact memory
so this
are things you should consider if you're
doing conditional join without number
let's look at the number implementation
it's also based on an algorithm again
I love open source people have put the
knowledge out there they've shared it
and
we owe a great deal to them by taking
their knowledge implementing it and
making it as performance as possible so
thanks to all those that have done all
the research that I'm building on
the algorithm is explained in a
publication the link is on the slide
the whole idea is get regions for your
let's data frame get regions for Your
Right data frame compare them the
regions from the left should be less
than or equal to Regions from the rights
if those conditions match those are the
rows that fulfill our the meter criteria
and then we create our data frame let's
look at the example same example volume
underscore one between volume low score
two a and body underscore 2B for those
of God Rhythm the driver is df1 the
let's data frame
because it is a greater than operation
we sorts value underscore one in
descending order
this
this particular algorithm requires that
the values from the Lux data frame
should always be at the top position
wise what do I mean take for instance
the value through the value let's say
value seven we can see this is value 7
right here
the it's always going to be at the very
top and then the next value that is
greater than is three so we have two two
region number two all the way down to
three but when we get here we realize
that
three isn't less than three so we skip
it and then we create a new region
number three and proceed on four and
proceed on it that way again the value
from the last data frame has to be
position wise at the top
we notice for the color-coded ones
that's twelve and seven there is no
value underscore one that is greater
than Twelve and seven so basically we
discard discard early reduce your search
space again that is the driving force
here reduce your search space we don't
want to blow up our data as much as we
can reduce our sex space the less work
we do the more we get
moving on to the next one we get our
regions
so we now source for value underscotes
for Value underscore one less than value
underscores will be now because it is a
lesson operator we sort the left data
frame in ascending order
again we run the same process position
wise the value from the left data frame
should be at the top so we have if you
look at that one and two uh above three
from value that's got two B so they are
region number two
well there is no value
from value underscore 2B that's number
one where it is greater than the value
from the let's data frame so one is not
greater than anything from value
underscore one in the land data frame we
get rid of it
the numbers value number seven and df1
is not less than any value in df2 for
volume.2b we get rid of it
gets your filter things out as early as
possible with use of such things that's
if you don't remember anything just keep
that in mind do less so you can get more
what was in our regions region one
region two and then we do the comparison
but those thought because it's easier
for
to do when you because we're going to
use binary search
so it's easier to sort it's easier when
you sort it rather so take for instance
that color coded one in region one again
the idea is the original one values for
df1 must be less than the region one
less than or equal to the region so
region one value sorry for the F2 and
the region two values for df1 must be
less than or equal to the region two
values for df2 so if you take for
instance for region one the very
important value there five
you do a burner research in region one
of df2 we can't find the position for a
position for it so we discard it
take the value number two the yellow
coded value there
we've considered it exists in DX
original one position wise it's there
and at that point we need to take the
value from region two and see which of
them is less than or equal to in region
two so we have four let's take as the
electorate value we have four over there
and then we compare it with four five
three and two four is less than or equal
to four four is less than or equal to
five but it is not less than three and
two so the only thing that we skip is
the rules four that has four and five so
have a look at this the color coding
should give you an idea of how the
parent is done
again reduce our search space there is
some optimization done within the code
but this is a generic overview of how it
works and then you get your results
one other advantage of number is the
parallelization opportunities it gives
so once you just there's this P range
function once you use it like you have
to use it appropriately it works wonders
in the right scenarios
one other option we have is equity and
non-epigence this was a it's a
relatively simple implementation all I
just did was intercept Panda's internal
house during indices at retro the
inequality conditions and then create
the data frame so instead of creating
the data frame and then filtering I do
the the filtering and then created a
data frame generally it is faster and I
know the soil cases a long-term approach
a better approach would be to integrate
this directly to Ponders something
similar to sql's where clause
performance why bother if it's not
performance so let's look at some
examples
this your mileage might vary so
depending on your machine or volume
running your code on but this is the
machine that I run it on
let's take the question number four
this is from Top DB dot DB is an SQL
it's a let's call it an SQL interface
where you can run SQL queries on pandas
it does much more than that I'm just
keeping it as simple as possible towards
the partners data frame this is from dog
DB's repo it's about 30 000 rows and we
need to get overlapping events if you
don't cut this you're enjoying think
about it 30 000 most squared that's
about what 900 million rows only for you
to find out maybe three thousand rules
that is inefficient a conditional joint
offers you a better way to go about it
so anyway we imported we create the
table when you run it in dog TV you get
a 10 milliseconds when you run it
without number you get 700 milliseconds
and which number you get 17 milliseconds
so we can see the performance right
there
this is just an eyeball thing just to
see that the value is much
everyone was on the tax audits this is
10 million rules again think about it 10
million rows Square that's that is a
crazy amount that you want to do a
Cartesian generally for you to filter
for
again thanks to the doc DB team this is
from their repo
create a table we run it on top DB you
get about 12 seconds when you run it
with number you get about 3.6 seconds it
takes forever when you don't use number
so this that's why you can find the
number the non-number code here
and we check the results is 98 000 rows
so imagine having to do a Cartesian
joint only for you to get 98 000 rules
it's inefficient this gives you a better
way to go about it if you're doing the
equity and the non-equal joints this is
pulled from stop overflow it's a
question from r i adapted it to pandas
so you have about ten thousand twenty
thousand words from your left data frame
100 000 on your rights
when you run it in dog DB super fast
milliseconds or you run it in Ponders
you get about 3.6 seconds that's with
the conditional join if you run it with
the classic pandas margin filter you're
hitting seven seconds so you can see
that with the conditional join you get
some performance and with dog TV you get
even more performance
check the role Out Sports 7 10 million
rules so this is just a Roadshow just to
be sure things much and then I decided
just to go crazy and say let's just
take out the equity joint and see how
far the program can push itself when you
run into a dog DB you get three seconds
where you run it with number with the
conditional joint you get 12 seconds but
you run into the number you get 21
seconds
check the number of rows it's about 267
million rows
again the idea is conditional joint
offers you an efficient way within
pandas
to get results for inequality joints
future work integration into partners
and Pi data table a field for Ponders
the API has to change for it to be able
to fit into pandas
I also noticed that more often than not
joins I means to an end aggregations or
some other reduction operations
follow-up after a joint so the question
is should we stick navigations will it
be more efficient and lastly and more
important suggestions for improvements
if you have a look at the code that you
feel there are things we can improve to
make it better please feel free to do so
have a look at dog DB uh it's a table
deployer and SQL databases these all
have implementations for inequality
joints and they could even offer more
performance than conditional joint at
the very least they want to use a
cartesia join when they are better
options
this uh links to that you can have a
look at when you have the time
thank you for listening